joining me here right in studio who I
had the pleasure to work with for many
years at ESPN when I was doing ESPN
radio coverage of major league baseball
the 20-year voice of ESPN Sunday Night
Baseball and now in his 20th season
calling games on the radio for the
Giants after many many years doing so
for the Orioles John Miller good to see
you sir how are you great good to see
you here in person on the show so I
guess let's start right away what has
happened to the team that led the
National League at the all-star break
and now they're in the three-way tie for
the one I don't think there's ever been
anything quite like it in the history of
Major League Baseball
the the real ironic part of it is that
not only did the Giants have the best
record in the game but some of their key
players were injured at one time the
second baseman the right fielder in the
third baseman were all gone at the same
time and so they had guys from the minor
leagues career minor leaguers they had
Ramiro Pena Grant Green Conor gillaspie
these guys all of a sudden became
regulars had a couple of rookies
platooning in the outfield Jared Parker
and Mac Williamson and they all actually
did really well they must have done well
because they had a stretch they were 40
and 15 but now pence got back Panik got
back and Duffy before he got back got
traded
they got Matt Moore these right-hander
for Matt Duffy so and they traded for
Eduardo Nunez who right now is one of
their best players yeah he's definitely
provided some energy there's no question
about that as a man and he had the one
loan manufactured run for Bumgarner
until the bull pen blew it again I mean
the back end is really good that Casias
disintegration is the only way to put it
has I mean I want to put on just one
person here but that is truly crushed
this team in the second half of the
season the bullpens been a problem all
season long but the the irony was when
those guys all got back they went into
slumps pence immediately went into a
terrible slump and so did Joe Panik and
the guys who had replaced them were
actually doing a lot better job of
hitting especially than the regulars
when they got back so which happens
sometimes
guy misses two months or six weeks or
whatever the bullpen has been a problem
in and out all season long that's been a
problem but I've never really seen
anything like what has happened recently
the last before last night the previous
nine games were they led in the ninth
inning which nine games you should be
nine and oh maybe eight one if something
went wrong right they were four and five
they lost five games of the last nine
that they were ahead in the ninth inning
now that was not something that was
happening all season then the previous
the rest of the season before that when
they had a lead going into the ninth
inning they were 86 and five so that's
remarkable down that's still not a great
record as Major League Baseball goes but
it's the difference between being maybe
five out behind the Dodgers with a
couple weeks ago or right there in the
hunt for the NL West well how about this
the Giants began play last night six
games back of the Dodgers in the West
the Dodgers have blown three games all
season which they led going to the ninth
inning the Giants have blown nine games
which they led going to the ninth inning
that's a six game difference the whole
difference between the two teams is
basically holding that ninth inning lead
versus not holding it so what does Bruce
Bochy do I mean how is he handling this
odd twist of fate or I mean it's an
even-numbered year don't doesn't don't
the baseball gods know that this is this
should be the Bochy Giants here well I
keep thinking that this may be just part
of the script because two years ago this
time of year with just 1012 days left
2014 there was no chance of the Giants
were going to win this World Series
there was there was no chance that they
were going to do anything in the
postseason they had one reliable
starting pitcher Bumgarner and they had
don't left fielder remember the left
fielder ended up being their third or
fourth string first baseman who
basically had never played left field in
his career he played a couple of days
the final weekend and never got a tough
chance and they asked Bochy well
Ishikawa again did you learn anything
can he play left field close enough put
him out there
and they ended up winning it also I
think they feel Posey and Bumgarner and
the main guys and team Pence that if
they get there they know how to win and
that they'll they'll wreak some havoc
but they have this last period of the
season to try to figure out that
late-inning bullpen which for no
contending team is this time you're ever
sort of holding auditions for the
closures job but that's where the Giants
aren't right now if you have this
problem the first month or two you work
it out and then you play the rest of the
season and go with what you've
discovered this is sort of uncharted
territory they have to be trying to do
that now it's just a few days left and
it's in if it doesn't work out in the
April May and the auditions maybe in
July you can go trade for somebody but
now you know there's there's no recourse
in that regard I've got John Miller
sitting here on the Rich Eisen show set
what happened with Bumgarner and Puig
the other day what happened there John I
think it Tony
it had almost nothing to do with the
moment which was Bumgarner throwing out
Puig at first and then being in close
proximity to each other after he did it
but plea immediately after he ran past
for a space he turned the wrong way if
you look at the video then he turned
towards second base you don't do that
after you're overrun first base every
major leaguer knows you know every minor
leaguer knows you don't turn towards
second base because if you end up being
called safe then they just walk over and
tag you out but he could not wait to
stop spin around and start glaring at
Bungo you hmm
yeah what and nobody had said anything
at that point and so I think it had
everything to do with the past between
these two guys so and and that's what
it's all about they've had their run-ins
and they've had their there glaring
matches and and also I think they have a
great deal of respect for each other do
you do the first time Bumgarner ever
faced clean he was burying that hard
cutter and fastball right in on the
hands and then he threw him his best
changeup away and Puig was right on it
hit a home run right down the
right-field line to digest a the first
time they'd ever seen each other and
Bumgarner was stunned
nobody does that he's never seen anybody
do that and he thought wow this guy's
pretty good so the rest of it is just
the the competitiveness I think but and
Puig being Puig and Bumgarner let's face
it there there was almost abroad in
spring training the Cubs and Giants were
playing and and I can't I think it was
Dexter Fowler
he struck out and then he starts talking
to the runner at second base with as if
Bumgarner is not even there and then
Bumgarner is the guy starts asking him
about the pitch like he's upset with the
guy at second and Bumgarner thinks he
means that the guy at second was tipping
pitches to him then a Bumgarner gets
upset starts screaming on everything
what's he screaming about you know and
that's all that was it was a spring
training game and was Bumgarner versus
arey out of the final score by the way
was I don't 16 to 14 neither guy said
well you're so good I love it that's
John Miller here on the Rich Eisen show
and you're saying that you haven't seen
much anything like what's happened to
the Giants over the last few months and
you called the Jeffrey Mayer catch if
you will and I want to talk about that
and other things from your from your
career I'm going to take a break we come
back in 60 takes the clock to do that in
the meantime I want to tell my listeners
and viewers that you have a chance to
win a $250 gift card from fanatics our
friends at fanatics you need to go to
Rich Eisen show calm right now though
and submit a picture that shows how you
are your team's ultimate fan so at the
end of the week we're all going to take
a look at these pictures that are on
Rich Eisen show com we will vote on
whoever has displayed their most
fanatical part of their fandom and you
get two hundred and fifty dollar gift
card from fanatics it's the world's
largest collection of official fan gear
from all the league's teams players you
love officially-licensed everything
fanatics back with John Miller and just
one minute's time you're on the Rich
Eisen show
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show one
of the more delightful aspects of
working at ESP and when I did John
Miller is that I got to meet you and I
got to pick your brain whenever I got to
call baseball games I've you were kind
enough to speak to me on the phone when
I was probably two years into my tenure
at ESPN asking you questions about
callin games and I I've recounted this
story before
when you were called into the show
earlier but I asked you what do I do if
I'm in the middle of telling a story and
the ball hits the bag hits somebody in
the top of their head and it bounces
like what do I do if I'm in the middle
of telling a story do you remember the
advice that you gave me about how I'm
able to just stop what I'm telling and
describing the action you remember that
piece of advice at all
it's okay if you did not I'm not
specifically remembering it but so let
me help you then the ball gets head you
have to describe it well you just said
that it's like you're talking your
friends in the most beautiful woman in
the world is walked in the room oh is it
you don't remember that's what I said
that's it and you're like your friends
and your friends and your friends
understand that is that you've stopped
telling the story pretty cool yeah and
then I once do years later do act it out
for me okay
um so here we go I'm telling this story
to John Miller and he doesn't recall
telling me this part of the story oh wow
she's beautiful and so anyway what's the
story that's it that by the way is that
that's exactly what years later when my
wife who you know from back at ESPN days
as well
and I were having they always stop
telling stories whenever she would walk
by nice yeah I have been wanting to
admit that to you for years I'm glad
that we're now getting it out in the
open but my wife and I we were having
dinner when there was a star she still
is that uh we were having dinner with
all people through mutual friends Donald
Trump and he stopped telling a story in
the middle of his story and saying well
she's beautiful and I told him about how
you John Miller gave me advice one day
and I've never seen it acted out in real
life in real person until he did it and
he just made his not sort of like his
Donald Trump face and they continue
telling you stuff you know but I
never heard you say what you just said
to me off camera what your children are
made you do so why don't you say what
are your kids like to do they just said
dad not that you're like a real old pass
a guy but you'd be a little more current
if you did Instagram because I always
have taken a lot of photos okay and then
I text into the kids and text them to my
wife or whoever and they said so just
put those pictures on the Instagram okay
I don't know anything about it but they
showed me how to do it they set it up
for me yes and and I've been doing it I
really enjoy it and it's it's and really
the whole point is to they give me the
big thing is hashtags it's not just the
photo or the film it's the the hashtag
that you put it with it and they give me
little things to put and and it's a lot
of fun John no it's hash tagging right
oh yeah so you want to take a picture of
Rich Eisen show when on fleek yeah sorry
yeah that's incredible rich aizen's wife
Susie on fleek
yeah I'm into that one that's a good one
yeah squad goals
squad gold that's good for you and your
answer yes this is all one's what is
your what is your what is your Instagram
handle John oh uh at it's the little at
shine yes uh John J Oh N mmm Miller and
SF Giants okay yeah so it's a baseball
thing well you could do real John Miller
you know people do that because they
want to either somebody's already if you
will
squatting on the real John Miller just
John Miller or it makes it seem like
you're more popular than that there's
fake accounts oh so you might want to
step you know I'm just I'll leave it to
your kids to tell you how to install now
I'll have to have a consult with the the
fam and see what they say about this
quad gold but the you know the funny
thing was opening day in San Francisco
and and then Scully is the best there
ever was and then always maintains his
cool you know he's like
the he's the James Bond of baseball
broadcasters no matter what happens
never breaks a sweat never gets overly
excited and just handles it opening day
in San Francisco Hunter Pence hits a
grand slam and very exciting the place
is going up it's a tight tense game and
I don't know what I was doing but I you
know way back there and I don't think
it's gone a grand slam for Buster Posey
good friend Hunter Pence and you know
John we actually we actually have do you
have that ready blowin let me pull it
cuz we we were gonna we were gonna play
it we actually have that let me let me
grab it so so well the point of yeah I'm
talking about it sure because of this
social media thing yeah Hunter Pence
immediately after that changes his
little bio on his Instagram and Twitter
and whatever else he's got and it now
reads at least it did at that time
I'm Buster Posey's good friend at Hunter
Pence and and he and Buster they did
little instagrams with pictures of each
other Here I am with my good friend
Hunter Pence and you know so on and so
forth oh that's great so they had a lot
of fun with it and I became very famous
in the worst possible way
oh when he screws up he recovers
beautifully John I've ever seen at the
recovery on after you screws up Hey look
wait one of the most incredible calls
I've ever heard was your call of
Geoffrey mere because there's no way
you're expecting in a big spot in a big
playoff game in Yankee Stadium a young
kid to reach over in rich Garcia to
botch the call and you were on it the
entire time it's a fan grabs it and rich
Garcia is calling it a homerun and
you're on it right away John I don't
know how how how are you able to as a
broadcaster to expect the unexpected
well and this also is this is another
mistake because I've made a lot of
mistakes and rich over the years not
just a hundred pence thing because
everything I was asking me that question
that night and the next the next day and
when the ball got out near right-field
Tony Tarasco is the right fielder he
squared up under
and I checked the TV monitoring the
network covering the game they had a
close-up of it and I saw the kid reach
out and intercept the ball and Carrasco
wasn't even he was squared up waiting to
catch it and then the umpire that I look
at the upper to see what he's calling
and he calls it a homerun so I I have
the kid grabbing it I had the umpire
making the call and then immediately
chastised him you know oh my goodness
that what a poor call by that umpire no
you're you're broadcasting you're seeing
what you're calling when you see so
they're all asking me how did you see
you must have been 600 feet away how did
you see all of that in the moment and so
I told I looked at the TV monitor which
that should have been my secret I
realize now no no no I mean you're
utilizing all of your tools that are
that are sitting right there and and you
mentioned VIN you know his last
broadcast is going to be in a booth next
to yours up at AT&T Park in San
Francisco what what is your relationship
with then well having done the Giants
game the last 20 years one of the great
benefits of that is that the Giants play
the Dodgers so often so we got to see if
any three times a year down here and
three times a year up in San Francisco
used to sit with him have dinner before
a game and for me I'm always just
picking his mind for stories because
he's got all the great stories he loves
to laugh
so that's been a lot of fun because he
grew up a giants fan yesterday by the
way I had to one of the all-time great
opportunities I did a sit-down interview
with Vinny for 35 minutes no kidding
it's hard to get Benny for 35 minutes
right now yeah cuz everybody in the
world wants to get him mmm
and it was before the something the
Giants are gonna do and it had some kind
of a special they're gonna produce on
their regional Sports Network up there
and at the ballpark things that they'll
show of that and I was trying to get him
to say what if it had been Horace
Stoneham and Russ Hodges had called you
instead of red barber in 1950 and you'd
end up you'd ended up broadcasting the
Giants games than the Dodgers you know
can you just give me a what-if and give
me a it's time for Giants base
and what'd he say well even as I was
starting into that he says oh you mean
do a it's time for Giants baseball so
you didn't do it the real one but he did
it so but you do a crazy Vin Scully
imitation so you want to do it right now
it's time for Giants baseball wrong by
farmer John freshly dressed Eastern fed
pure pork sausage mm-hmm Wow you know
years ago before I was at ESPN uh Vinnie
was doing the game of the week at NBC he
was in New York in the studio I was in
Seattle in the studio where the Orioles
are planned and a Sunday morning show on
ESPN
might have been you I can't remember it
could with the host was but he's
interviewing the two of us about the
pennant races and then out of the blue
he asked me if I'd do this Vin Scully
impression so I do a thing of Vinnie and
Japanese that he's so famous now that
even in Japan the broadcaster's try to
sound like him and and I thought it was
a little bit of a tribute you know and I
do Vinnie and Jeff and then Vinnie
starts speaking Japanese from the studio
in New York which I thought now that's
the best ever what does that sound like
what oshawa Caraco in the stadium knee
or demise Hajime my stage does your
ishka low ball two
but now the host man says to Vinny says
now then how do you feel about John not
doing this impression of you and and
then then basically says he he knows
there's a fine line between making fun
and having fun oh sure but he takes it
as all being in good fun although he's
much happier being the imitate E
rather than the imitator and then I do
just what you're doing and now 20
minutes later I'm walking back to the
hotel through downtown Seattle thinking
did did I just get cut up into a
thousand pieces you didn't even know it
Wow now that is good John Miller here on
the Rich Eisen show would you mind
sticking around one more session wrap up
this
Thanks before he sent you sous-chef as
Ravine for the finale pull up a chair
Wow
and stick around one more segment take
an interview well I've got a good idea
for one last segment here we'll have
we'll have you take a selfie with me as
Vin Scully on your Instagram account
okay so get ready for that that's John
Miller next here on the Rich Eisen show
John's got 41 thousand followers on
Instagram oh I know I saw by the way
this is it just a two-minute 20-second
long TV all crushed okay last week the
person in like yesterday in your chair
Jeff Garlin the actor and comedian did
not know we were on the air live and
said something very not-safe-for-work
mmm-hmm
so I just want to make sure you
understand from crying out PJ yeah that
could happen here Joe what's your
favorite ballpark of all the ones that
cuz you've been in so many well as a
broadcaster going to Fenway there's
there's nothing better than that because
the game is so unusual at Fenway with
the big wall and everything that's right
in front of the crowd is great and when
the Giants went there this year for
interleague play it was fabulous the
Jets had thousands of people had made
the trip to go to family wanna see
Fenway sure and they started doing less
good yeah and the Red Sox fans still
he's just trying to boom and throw
things at him and whatnot started doing
competing Let's Go Red Sox and is the
most wild thing of it I mean I've done a
lot of Yankee Red Sox games they're on
ESPN Sunday night games and I've never
seen that electricity in that ballpark
because of let's go John let's go Reds
our lads got you know and it was loud
and it went through a whole inning like
that so well I mean I remember when I
was doing ESPN radio studio shows and
then for the World Series I got to go on
the road there was a lot of World Series
games in that old Yankee Stadium that
was I'll never forget it but I look I
grew up a Yankee fan from Staten Island
so it was particularly special
they were the best fans to me in that
era because and after September 11th we
were there almost the whole month yes
and they just started things like Jorge
Posada would come up and a whole section
we go hip hip and then they'd all jump
up Jorge
and by the fourth at-bat the whole
stadium did it it was just phenomenal
and yeah you called Jeter's home runners
mr. November yeah that home run uh World
Series yeah he went to it in this tight
tense game a huge game he goes to Torre
it's just past midnight into November he
says mr. Torre are you still going to
manage he says what do you mean it's the
tenth inning he says well your contract
is expired I've never heard that story I
kind of thought maybe you just walk out
of here and little bub house and take
your head straps off at Eddie get a home
run fantastic
you're listening to the Rich Eisen show
there's a high drive deep in the left
centerfield it's on its way
Grand Slam for Buster Posey's good
friend Hunter Pence the six giant listen
we're gonna get it order save John man
what a save his first four RBI I mean
that's a fantastic save I did you know
on my Instagram Marty Brennaman put a
note in said that is the greatest save
in broadcast history you're my idol and
I thought now that's what I'm known for
I want to thank Matt Ryan Mark Wahlberg
James Lofton and John Miller here in
studio on the Rich Eisen show Ed O'Neill
of Modern Family will be on tomorrow
show here along with Eric Davis do you
want to take a selfie for your instagram
yeah do me a favor call the the selfie
that you're about to do as if you're Vin
Scully while we're doing the selfie here
oh dude as a video you know you have to
do it as a video but just call it
yourself if you want like you're like
describe what you're doing as Vin Scully
taking the Instagram account photograph
Here I am ladies and gentleman pull up a
chair as I do something that I have no
idea how did you and it should be
marvelous I'm doubtful it'll be on fleek
but I'm with Rich Eisen who is for my
money
goat Wow
hashtag good hash - OH or you can use
the emoji I can use the emoji goat oh
there's a goat yes oh oh this is good
yes John you're the best you are the
best enjoy the rest of the season die
out forget to call playoff games no ciao
try to build up my ratings on the
Instagram you know it looks like I lost
a hundred I went from 41 since I've been
on this show I was at 41,000 when I
walked in and now it's 40 point 9 now
that know there is absolutely
no chance of that don't worry all right
that's just it's a blip you're on my
casting ratings you know you're loud I
look at it as a rating you're on fleek
oh do you want to do the quick poll
question real quick John what's your
favorite Bill Murray movie he's 66 years
old today
King pinstripes Groundhog Day
Ghostbusters Caddyshack
well stripes is fabulous and Groundhog
Day fabulous if they're on if I'm
flipping through and late late at night
at a hotel my tribe they need the remote
drop right I'm yeah I love it
I'm I'm it I'm on on which one did you
choose well I think I think ride hard
Davis it's so funny and it every time I
see it it's funny and it's so clever I
just think that's one of the greats
John thanks for coming on have a great
broadcast tonight and beyond please come
back next time you're in Los Angeles my
pleasure John Miller here on the Rich
Eisen show again Eric Davis Ed O'Neill
and you tomorrow see them the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience